One item to consider before we get to the interviews themselves,
is about the jobs requiring autonomous system skills.
While certain companies do have more overarching titles,
it's most common that jobs you apply to will have
much more specific roles like motion plane engineer,
controls engineer, or perception engineer.
As such, the interviews you're about to see will each
be specific to one type of these roles.
We suggest going through each one of these,
as you'll see different individuals going through
their own separate approaches to problem-solving their interview question.
While the question itself might not be specific to the role you're looking for,
perhaps the interviews thinking will boost you in your own interview.